you are an explorer seeking the unknown
but while others have explored the
frontiers of the outer world
you traverse the inner recesses of your
business
looking deep within your processes and
systems to uncover
new opportunities and like all the
greats
you know you can't do it alone it takes
the right team
and the right tools tools that can take
you
even further ai-powered automation
is the ultimate engine for driving
discovery transforming work
and simplifying operations so you can
make time
for brilliance each innovation builds
upon the last
converging business and i.t to fuel a
never-ending cycle of optimization
some would say all the great discoveries
have already been made
we believe it's just the beginning
what will you discover
[Music]